welcome back to Facebook prime minister
Rishi sunak has today been accusing
gutter politics after personally posting
an attack ad tweet which claimed Labor's
on the same side as criminal gangs
smuggling migrants into Britain the
labor itself was accused of the same
thing after a viral marketing Camp
benecu soon Act of not believing abusers
should go to jail and if you think we've
got it bad take a look at this
conspiracy Laden video posted in America
today the video is posted by an arms
length Group which makes viral pro-trump
content and Trump often shares their
videos
if I was the Deep State and I wanted to
destroy America
I would rig the election with a puppet
candidate I would create a false flag
that allows for mail-in ballots
I would be in charge of the ballot
counting machines
I would create a false flag to blame all
who question the results of the election
I would make sure all crimes I ever
committed never happened I would
prosecute my biggest competition I would
make sure they could never run for
office ever again I would push my
pedophilia Ambitions on you
well that goes over several minutes
along the same lines are these the new
moral battle field of which next year's
elections are set to be for joining me
now is political strategist and polls to
Franklin and Donald Trump's Pastor Mark
Burns welcome to both of you Franklin's
um you tweeted this the most alarming
political ad you've seen this year why
I I still don't know how to describe it
I don't know how to respond I was so
stunned at how divisive how negative and
how it's designed to create anxiety and
fear and and genuine dislike and
distrust of people pierce at some points
you have to say enough is enough and
I'll be curious to hear from the pastor
when he counsels the former president is
this really who we are as a people is
this really who we are as a country does
this add or detract from our political
discourse it's getting worse and worse
and this ad frighten the living hell out
of me so I expect you're going to see a
lot of it as a result right so Pastor
Burns I mean I watched it and it just is
this is what I call Rabbit Hole
conspiracy theory claptrap masquerading
as mainstream politics I mean surely you
wouldn't defend a lot of what you heard
and saw in that in that commercial would
you well Pierce let me just say this um
there's a reason why uh president Donald
Trump is leading in the polls on
Statewide there's a reason he's leading
in the polls uh nationally there's a
reason why um he is still the front
runner even though you had all of the
the fraudulent indictments um that are
coming against them uh you know I can't
led by the Biden and his uh doj which
has been weaponized to essentially
interfere with an election uh there's a
reason why the American people are still
choosing Donald Trump because he is
literally the modern day Julius Caesar
right it was the Senators the elite that
killed off uh Julius Caesar it wasn't
the Common Man Donald Trump speaks to
the Common Man and that's why he's
having a two-tier system in America and
they're tied up being led by people like
Joe Biden and the Biden crime
relation to what Frank just said is it
healthy for America or American politics
or American democracy that you have such
a nihilistic ad like this flying around
social media such a dystopian look at
the country you know America was built
on Unity of a country that was welcoming
to all that fought together to become
the greatest country on Earth this kind
of thing looks to me like it's an
incredibly divisive attempt to brush off
everything that's negative about Trump
is absolutely invented by the Deep state
they're all out to get him he's Julius
Caesar the knives are flying in his back
it could be that you know a lot of the
stuff that Trump's been alleged to have
done is completely true and he shouldn't
have done it we'll find out in the court
cases but why would you as if
be happy for such overt negativity to be
swarming around America
well Frank uh what what is truthful and
you hit it right on the nail that the
American Revolution took place because
the people came together for truth like
we had no representation right in
England so that people came together
because of Truth fact and the fact is
right now we have a a government uh um
that is pushing a a doj to be
weaponizing against Donald Trump number
two we are changing sexes in America
there's a reason why Donald Trump is is
touching the Christian Community by
saying that he would not allow grown men
to participate in female sports the fact
that we're questioning the identity of
biology male what is a male what is a
female but not questioning Pfizer not
questioning the the covet vaccines that
has literally dumb harm that's not
conspiracy people are actually in the
ground right that is not a conspiracy
again
let me finish
so the American people peers want truth
the American people want fact they don't
want to be killed in the dark anymore
I don't think a pastor should be saying
that the only thing the covered vaccines
did was Jesus
I don't think a pastor should be saying
the only purpose
had to deal with the Roman season Jesus
himself
this is my church
my church not yours I don't think it's
because Jesus Christ
because he was willing to go against the
person talking because he gave the truth
after what you've just said about Kobe
vaccines was not the truth yes you had
some adverse side effects but yes
actually it saved a lot of millions of
people from going under the ground
Franklin's um what do you do when you
have Donald Trump's own Pastor who signs
up on all this stuff and thinks that
actually it's all true
you ask your question rather than make a
statement is this the proper discourse
that we should be having on your show
is this the kind of behavior that we
should be emulating for your children
are these the priorities are kids
learning what they need to know to be
successful in University career in life
or is this the right approach my
challenge in this is that I don't
necessarily disagree with a lot of the
points either raised by the pastor or
raised by the ad it's how it's done and
peers I've come my entire career I've
suddenly figured out that there's some
things more important than the election
decency civility respect these are
values that a good country Champions and
we're losing them in America and one
last point
we don't have to demonize each other to
prove that we ourselves are correct it
doesn't require the destruction of the
opposition or not the enemy
the destruction of the opposition to
promote the things that we promote and
here's the truth you've always stood for
and I'm sorry for this conversation
because frankly it's an embarrassment
yeah Pastor all I would say to you
Pastor is your job as a pastor surely is
to bring people together not to fuel
Division and when the truth when you
speak yeah but your idea of what the
truth is and mine might be different you
should be out of respect the fact that I
have a different opinion to you or the
Frank does
okay Pierce so I get all that I hear
what you're saying but the reality of it
is you're ignoring the fact that there
is but two sexes in the world there's
male there's no I agree with you about
it now we have a society otherwise
I agree with you about that Donald Trump
is fighting against this is why he is
leading in the polls this is why he's
raising money because he is God's
anointed and I understand that the
powers that be like yourself are coming
it's not love Frank Frank Lux I love
frank but but Frank course he you know
as much as I love frank and thank you
Frank my father has got knee surges you
and I had a great conversation years ago
so I love you and I respect you but you
also said that Hillary Clinton was going
to be the next president of the United
States of America so we know that you
don't like anything mag but the American
people do right and the American people
are behind Donald Trump that's why he's
leaving the party
family weaponize the doj listen if we're
going to talk about videos how about you
talk about the status video and his Nazi
imagery
we're not here to talk about the
scientists final word to you Frank make
it quick please we're running out of
time I'm sorry that I did this interview
and I appreciate that the pastor likes
me this is so inappropriate for British
audiences for American audiences and if
this is the direction we're headed in
here's we're gonna have a really bad 18
months yeah I think I agree with you
it's got to be a more civil way to to
debate I totally agree Frank uh good to
see you both though Frank thank you for
joining me Pastor thank you for joining
me maybe got a little easy with the
president Trump next time you see him
tell him to just wins dial things down a
bit dial it down a bit dial down the
rhetoric not everyone has to hate each
other there's different opinions uh good
to see you both thank you